GREG GUTFELD.
"THE FIVE."
>> WAS I WRONG A FEW WEEKS AGO
TO SOMEHOW GIVE THE IMPRESSION
TO PEOPLE THAT I WAS CRAZY AND
SUCCESSFULLY OPPOSED TIME AND
AGAIN?
YES, I WAS.
I REGRET IT.
I'M SORRY FOR THE PAIN OR
MISCONCEPTION THAT IT MAY HAVE
CAUSED ANYBODY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: FINALLY JOE BIDEN
APOLOGIZED FOR NOT BEING SLEEPY
BUT FOR ADMITTING HE CAN WORK
WITH PEOPLE HE DISAGREED WITH
INCLUDING AWFUL DEMOCRATS FROM
HIS VERY OWN PARTY.
TO MAKE HIS POINT HE USED
SEGREGATIONISTS WHO WERE THE
BACKBONE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, WE LIVE IN A
WORLD WHERE DELIBERATE
MISINTERPRETATION IS WEAPONIZED
KAMALA HARRIS NEW BIDEN WAS NOT
COMPLEMENTING SEGREGATIONIST.
ON THE CONTRARY, IT WAS THE
HEINOUSNESS THAT SERVE THE
EXAMPLE WELL.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
AS LONG AS THERE IS ROOM ENOUGH
TO SLAY DAN, I'VE GOT YOU.
THERE'S ROOM ENOUGH AND AMONG
DEMOCRATS, SAME THOUGHTS YOU,
SPEAKING WITH THE POWER.
AN EXAMPLE OF WORKING WITH
RACISTS BECAME JOE'S UPPER PARTY
FOR CROSS BURNERS AND WROTE EACH
OTHER LOVE POEMS.
BIDEN LIMPS ALONG LIKE
INTER-GAZELLE OVER THE SERENGETI
UNAWARE HIS APOLOGIES BUT THE
FIRST IN A LONG LINE OF ONES HE
WILL BE GIVING BECAUSE ONE IS
NEVER ENOUGH AND TWO, JUST THE
APPETIZER.
HE WILL BE APOLOGIZING UNTIL THE
DESERT IS SERVED AND CHECK IT
SERVED.
JOE HAS BEEN ALONG FOR A LONG
TIME, JUST TO LIFE IS A CREEP OF
COLLABORATION AND WITCH BURNING.
REMEMBER JOE WAS BORN LESS THAN
100 YEARS AFTER THE END OF
SLAVERY.
SO I WANT TO FEEL BAD FOR JOE
BUT THEN I REMEMBER THIS.
>> THEY DON'T WANT PEOPLE
VOTING.
BLACK FOLKS VOTING.
UNCHAIN WALL STREET.
THEY WILL PUT YOU ALL BACK IN
CHAINS.
>> BIDEN CAN SMEAR WITH THE BEST
OF WHAT GOES AROUND COMES AROUND
AND TODAY EVERYTHING COMES
AROUND UNTIL JOE GOES AROUND.
SPEAKING OF GOING AWAY, IT WOULD
OFFER A MOMENT OF SILENCE FOR
ERIC SWALWELL WHO NO ONE WANTS
TO MOVE A MOMENT OF SILENCE FROM
THE SHOW.
BUT YOU WANT TO SHOW HIS EXIT,
WHATEVER?
>> WE HAVE TO BE HONEST ABOUT
OUR OWN CANDIDACIES.
AMERICAN AUTHOR, WROTE IN A LONE
MOUNTAIN, THERE WILL BE A TIME
WHEN YOU CAN LEAVE EVERYTHING
AND GO.
THAT WILL BE THE BEGINNING.
TODAY ENDS OUR PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, BUT IT IS THE
BEGINNING OF AN OPPORTUNITY IN
CONGRESS WITH A NEW PERSPECTIVE.
>> Greg: JESSE ARE YOU AS
CRUSHED AS I AM?
YOU CALLED IT.
>> Jesse: A LITTLE UPSET
BECAUSE I HAD JELL-O BRAND FOR
US TO DROP IT YOU HAD
ERIC SWALWELL SO GREG WINS AND I
LOSE.
I'M GETTING USED TO IT.
ON THE BIDEN SITUATION, BIG
DIFFERENCE IN TRUMP AND BIDEN,
BIDEN RUNS AWAY FROM CONTROVERSY
IN TRUMP RUNS TOWARDS IT AND IF
YOU LOOK AT TRUMP THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, THE
CONTROVERSIAL THINGS IN HIS OWN
PARTY, TOUGH ON TARIFFS, THE
BORDER, TRAVEL BAN AND EVEN HIS
PERSONAL SO-CALLED SCANDALS AND
DUG IN HARDWARE AS JOE BIDEN
OVER THE COURSE OF FOUR MONTHS
BASICALLY HAS CHANGED POSITIONS
OR APOLOGIZED ON THE HYDE
AMENDMENT, SEGREGATIONIST, ANITA
HILL, INAPPROPRIATE TOUCHING
COME OF THE CHINESE THREAT.
THIS IS THE WORST APOLOGY SINCE
IT WAS FOREST AND HE DIDN'T WANT
TO GIVE IT.
HE HAD TO GIVE IT.
THE BASIS LEADING HIM INSTEAD OF
HIM LEAVING THE BASE.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE HE HAS THE
PRESIDENTIAL TIMBER WHEREAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH AN APPROVAL
RATING HAS GOTTEN SO FAR, THE
LATEST POLL BY ABC,
"WASHINGTON POST," AND I THINK
THE MUELLER REPORT HAS SLOWED
THINGS DOWN.
YOU HAD TWO SUCCESSFUL OVERSEAS
TRIPS, EUROPE, ASIA AND THE
AMERICAN IS TRYING TO CONTRAST
THE PRESIDENT WITH THESE OTHER
DEMOCRATS AND LOOKING AT HIM
MORE FAVORABLY WITH THE GREAT
ECONOMIC NEWS COMING OUT IN JUN
JUNE.
>> Greg: ALSO AMERICA'S FEMALE
SOCCER TEAM, THE WORLD CUP,
DONALD TRUMP ONE.
HE LED THEM TO VICTORY.
>> Juan: WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THE GOLDEN BOOT AND A LOT OF
AMERICANS WOULD LIKE TO GIVE HIM
THE GOLDEN BOOT.
>> Dana: NOW WATCH IT!
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT THOSE
NUMBERS, POLL NUMBERS, WHAT IS
THE DISAPPROVAL AGAIN?
>> Greg: OBAMA AT THE EXACT
SAME TIME --
I WATCH THAT RELIGIOUSLY.
>> Juan: I WILL SAY THIS.
I THINK JOE BIDEN'S GETTING BACK
IN THE FIGHT.
AND THE CAMPAIGN, BUT HE'S ON
THE WAY BACK AND YOU HEAR INSIDE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT HE
SLOW NOW, SLOW TO ANNOUNCE AND
STILL GETTING BACK TO HIS A-GAM
A-GAME.
>> Dana: SLOW JOE.
SLOW JOE IS HAVING A HARD TIME.
SLEEPY JOE.
>> Juan: WHO KNOWS, BUT I WILL
SAY WHAT YOU DO GET IS
DONALD TRUMP, KATIE IMMEDIATELY
TWEETING ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
HE'S NOT TWEETING ABOUT HARRIS
OR POCAHONTAS.
HE'S TWEETING ABOUT THE GUY THAT
HE WORRIES WILL BEAT HIM.
GIVE HIM THE GOLDEN BOOT AND
THAT IS JOE BIDEN.
>> Greg: IS IT SLOW JOE WITH
MOJO ORINOCO?
>> Katie: HOW LONG WILL IT
TAKE JOE BIDEN TO GET INTO THE
RACE?
THIS IS CRUCIAL -- CRUCIAL
TIMING AT THE TOP OF THE PACK
AND HE KNOWS BECAUSE OF THAT THE
CHANCES GOING DOWN ARE INEVITABL
CHANCES GOING DOWN ARE INEVITABE
CHANCES GOING DOWN ARE INEVITABI
CHANCES GOING DOWN ARE INEVITABN
CHANCES GOING DOWN ARE INEVITABA
CHANCES GOING DOWN ARE INEVITABY
HAS TO HOLD ONTO THE FRONT SPOT.
HE KEEPS LEANING ON THE OBAMA
LEGACY AND NOT ONLY IS OBAMA NOT
ENDORSING HIM BUT PEOPLE IN THE
CAMP OR RUNNING AWAY FROM HIM AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE AND OPENLY
CRITICIZING HIM.
DAVID AXELROD AGAIN OVER THE
WEEKEND SAYING, I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS GUY CAN MAKE IT TO THE END
BASED ON ALL OF THE
FLIP-FLOPPING.
IN THE END, WHAT IS THE POINT OF
HAVING A MODERATE LANE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY IF JOE BIDEN
WILL JUST CONTINUALLY CHANGE HIS
POSITION?
IF HE GETS TO A GENERAL AND
BECOMES THE NOMINEE, WHICH IS
NOT INEVITABLE, BY THE WAY, WHAT
WILL HE ACTUALLY RUN ON
CONSIDERING HE'S CHANGING HIS
POSITION?
I APOLOGIZE WHAT I SAID A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO.
WELL THIS IS A POSITION OVER THE
COURSE OF 30 YEARS OF YOUR
CAREER IN THE SENATE.
ARE YOU APOLOGIZING FOR THAT
TOO?
WHAT IS HIS PLATFORM?
I'M NOT SURE.
>> Greg: HE'S TURNING MODERATE
LIEN INTO LOMBARD STREET.
>> Dana: RUNNING OUT OF ROAD.
OKAY, THIS NEW POLITICAL CLIMATE
DOES NOT SEEM TO SUIT HIM WELL.
SO HE'S BEEN RUNNING FOR OFFICE
FOR 40 YEARS.
WHEN YOU ARE RUNNING AS A
VICE PRESIDENT ON A TICKET WHERE
PRESIDENT OBAMA IS POPULAR, YOU
ARE RUNNING ON A TICKET AND HE
WAS A GOOD VICE PRESIDENT.
I'M NOT SAYING HE WASN'T.
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
YOU WEAR THEM THE BEST CANDIDATE
FOR THIS POLITICAL MOMENT THAT
WE ARE IN.
THINK OF THE PROGRESSION.
HE SAID WHAT HE SAID.
THEN HE TOLD CORY BOOKER THAT
CORY BOOKER SHOULD APOLOGIZE.
I'M NOT GOING TO APOLOGIZE.
HE'S GOT SOME FIGHT IN HIM.
HE DOES AN INTERVIEW AND HE SAID
I DID NOT EXPECT FOR THEM TO
COME AFTER ME.
THEN HE SAYS, I'M ACTUALLY
SORRY, THINK ABOUT THIS DEBATE
IN THE NEXT THREE WEEKS.
IT IS LIKELY THE WAY THINGS ARE
GATHERED THAT ELIZABETH WARREN
WILL BE ON THE STAGE WITH HIM.
IF I AM HER, WHAT ELSE CAN I GET
HIM ON?
HOW CAN WE GET HIM ON
PROGRESSION?
YOU CAN GO BACK 45 YEARS AND
FIND SOMETHING TO HELP SUPPORT
WALL STREET.
OR BERNIE SANDERS WILL GO AFTER
HIM ON HEALTH CARE.
YOU CAN SEE THE SAME TYPE OF
PROGRESSION HAPPENING TO THE
POINT WHERE YOU WERE SAYING THE
BASIS LEADING HIM TO POSITIONS
HE DOESN'T NECESSARILY HOLD.
>> Greg: YOUR POINT ABOUT --
IT WAS LIKE WHEN I TOOK MY
DRIVER'S TEST I HAD TO USE A CAR
THAT WAS 20 YEARS OLD BECAUSE I
COULDN'T RIDE THE CAR MY WIFE
HAD TO.
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND ANY OF THE
GADGETS.
IT HAD THE REARVIEW MIRROR MOVIE
THING.
YEAH, I KNOW, SO I HAD TO IN
ORDER TO PASS THE TEST USE A
TAURUS FROM 1999.
>> Dana: IT WILL ALSO GET YOU
TO YOUR DESTINATION.
>> Juan: BIDEN FOR ALL THAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT --
>> Dana: PEOPLE STILL LIKE HIM
CAN I GET IT.
>> Juan: AND I THINK GOING
BACK TO WHAT JESSE SAID,
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
"THE WASHINGTON POST," HANOVER,
TRUMP AND THE POLE.
>> Dana: NOBODY ELSE IS ABOVE
THAT POLE.
>> Juan: BUT I THINK THE KEY
AS WE ARE LOOKING AT BIDEN TODAY
AND AN APOLOGY IS TO UNDERSTAND
THAT HIS BASES SUPPORT IN THE
MODERATE LIEN THAT GREG IS
TALKING ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, REMAINS VERY
STRONG.
>> Greg: I HOPE IT DOES.
THE SAME POLE HILLARY BEATING